[Música]
olha isto tira
mesmo mais um unboxing datino hoje temos
11 produtos eu vou mostrar um por um vou
dizer quanto custa e vocês aí em baixo
têm também o link para sacar a aplicação
e se quiserem ter descontos usem o meu
código Primeiro produto tá aqui embaixo
sou eu eu sou o primeiro produto compra
epa já comprei Primeiro produto Malta
temos aqui um peluche Zinho vocês
conhecem esta figura baby in Yellow que
aqu jogo bastante Popular há do anos
atrás mas eu curto para caraças deste
pel eu tenho ali pel de F night Freddy
este vai fazer companhia tá aqui o preço
Malta vai sempre aparecer aqui os preços
Ok próximo produto tem tudo para ser
scam vamos testar aqui Aqui nós temos um
lápis que supostamente é um lápis que
não se gasta um lápis infinito vamos lá
testar bem a ponta dele parece tipo todo
em carvão vamos dar aqui um autógrafo
olha funciona está a escrever
vamos L fazer o teste eu acho que isto
não gasta mesmo que magia que bruxaria é
esta Malta eu acabei de riscar com toda
a minha força e não gasta a
ponta isto não gasta se algum de vocês
souber o segredo deste lápis comentem
embaixo porque eu quero aprender a a
magia mano Isto é BR próximo
produto olha até já me tinha esquecido
de comprar isto isto é nada mais nada
menos que um telefone vintage não Isto é
um chuveiro de plástico portanto isto
tem tudo para dar errado botão do on e
do off um choveiro com on e off oh oh
não é só abrir a torneira já sei é
porque tem duas funções duas funções Ah
tipo jato Ah isto regula Claro é faz bí
o rabinho bem isto aqui tem uma entrada
que eu acho que é compatível com meu
chuveiro e vamos testar bem Eu espero
que seja compatível
ah encaixa
perfeito assim é igual ao
nosso assim é mais fraquinho assim é
mais ah is tem um jato bom ok se eu
carregar Stop o que é que acontece
aprovadíssimo 8 de 10 só não dou um 10
porque não se come olha queres explicar
o que é que é aquilo ali é o Xavier
próximo
produto isto só vem
assim Malta acabamos de compr um
autoclicker sim Vocês ouviram bem um
autoclicker para que que eu quero isto
não sei ok Isto é um dispositivo com uma
mola funciona por USB Claro isto tem que
ter Power eia bem calma isto está tudo
confuso aqui e aqui tem um sensor
metálico que deve simular o nosso dedo a
voz misteriosa que vocês já sabem quem é
vai colocar aqui já não é misteriosa já
não é misteriosa ela vai colocar aqui um
jogo qualquer ou um site qualquer que
tenha cliques e vamos fazer o teste tá a
funcionar Olha aí é cliques ticos mano
nem tenho que fazer nada produto 100%
aprovado em que mais é que achas que dá
para
usar para dar muitos likes likes no
tiktok
né sabes que isso dá Ban não dá Ah não
dá se descobre olha se tiveres com o
dedo bué
rápido Vais levar B mas o tiktok sabe
que estás a usar o dedo próximo
produto Isto são literalmente sapatos
invisíveis eu comprei em xl porque o meu
pé é o 47 né tenho um pé gigante Eu sei
mas olha pá eu achoi que este dedo tá
bem saliente n e pá tá bué separado eu
não tenho o dedo assim mano sem joanet
olha acabou ui com joanet esquece este
sapato senão isto tinha ainda tinha que
ter o exra aqui é pá que
exagero
teu já me descalce para testar os nossos
sapatos invisíveis e reparem na minha
unha tá caótica nem te atrevas a rir da
minha unha Eu nem quero rir eu quero
vomito nem te atrevas que horror Isto
vai dar bosta como é que eu vou colar
isto Ah isto estica isto estica
Calma eu não sinto tipo eu não sinto eu
não sei explicar o feeling o feeling é
muito
bom resulta no dia a dia andar em casa e
tudo mais agora na passadeira Isto vai
dar bolhas em 10 minutos
ah
ah olha tudo o que havia ali de
impurezas saiu com isto aqui isto ainda
dói a
arrancar é doloroso não funciona assim
tão bem olha aproveitem se quiserem
próximo produto O que é que nós temos
aqui
Ah já sei o que é esta coisa de plástico
serve para vocês aproveitarem o máximo
da vossa pasta de dentes o zuk outra vez
ve para eu já te disse que eu não sou eu
não sou eu não sou com as tuas amigas
percebe Eu acho que é enfiar a pasta
aqui
ah agora vamos enfiar aqui por dentro e
rodar
ah funciona e isto aqui vai puxar toda a
pasta que h para cima Isso é incrível é
muito bom reparem como aqui em cima aqui
em cima ainda tem este bocadão todo de
pasta que dá para usar ela fica ali
enroladinha mano perfeito perfeito Isto
é barato e Vale super pena porque vocês
economizam na pasta espera eu tenho que
ter atenção é abrir aqui um pouquinho
porque depois se eu abrir isto isto
espirra Ah é preciso ter cuidado próximo
produto é um produto que cabe no
bolso o que é isto perguntam vocês
também não sei estou a descobrir
convosco Ah já sei Malta Isto é um
dispensador de perfume para que é que
isto serve serve para vocês levarem o
perfume para o trabalho para a escola
para uma date Qualquer coisa vocês pegam
nisto abastecem com o vosso perfume que
já TM em casa e levam para qualquer
lugar muito pequeno muito portátil vamos
ver se
funciona eu não sei se isto está a
encher está a encher sim pá eu vou
encher mais porque eu vou usar isto
mesmo Imagina eu consigo levar o meu
perfume comigo para todo o lugar dentro
do bolso Malta isto para
conquistar entrou-me na boca próximo
produto voz misteriosa isso vamos embora
o que ela tirou para a mesa temos aqui a
um preço muito bom também eu não sei se
vocês se lembram mas o sinal da PS2 para
a televisão é meio analógico né Tem
aquelas três bananas aqueles três cabos
meio estranhos o amarelo o vermelho e o
branco e esse sinal não é muito bom para
as televisões mais recentes Então esta
peça vai ser super útil para vocês
ligarem o cabo componente eu não sei se
estou a falar bosta se é cabo componente
se tem outro nome mas é o cabo da
Playstation vocês vão ligar Ah não isto
liga é diretamente na PlayStation ah
espa isto ainda é melhor vou testar isto
num vídeo que vou postar estar aqui no
canal sobre a Playstation 2 Ok eu não
vou testar agora mas eu tenho quase
certeza que isto funciona e este cabo
vai ajudar na alimentação desta
peça Acabei de estragar a peça agora já
não funciona já não funciona rifando É
rifando mano é rifando o que é que tens
aí para mim voz misteriosa uma escova
para lavar os dentes uma escova para
lavar os dentes Olha estou mesmo a
precisar temos uma vassoura multiusos
que dá para limpar tudo eu como vos digo
tudo é tudo esta vassoura serve para
limpar teclados vem com esta peça para
arrancar as teclas do teclado aqui por
dentro tem mais esta peça para limpar os
her poots ou qualquer outro fone tem
esta parte aqui com uma escovinha tem
esta ponteira para tirar a cera por
dentro dos fones que é horrível e toda a
gente tem não finam que tem higiene toda
a gente tem Ceda nos fonos eu tenho aqui
os meus irap podos dois vamos começar já
por limpá-los olha olha olha a sair
tudo Malta Isto é completamente normal
Ok não sou eu que sou um badalou olha
isto tira mesmo olha
aqui pronto esta parte está testada
vamos aqui dentro Como podem ver a minha
caixa também tá horrível Olha como
funciona como é que tem que ser aí não
faço ideia Ok eu talvez seja um
porcalhão mesmo agora vamos deixar isto
aqui de lado e vamos testar a
vassourinha a vassourinha é só voltarmos
a colocar aqui vamos pegar o meu teclado
tá horrível por sinal tá muito sujo
vamos já arrancar aqui o
set ó a peça saiu perfeitamente porque é
que tem pelos agora é só passar aqui a
escova ó o pó já saiu todo o pó aqui de
cima saiu
todo ah saiu mesmo sujidade Olha repara
Ya tá ali um pelo de lado e tudo é
porque estas farpas aqui todas como são
Compridas elas entram bem na tecla ó é
só passar assim obviamente que o ideal é
arrancar todas as as teclas não é Fazer
uma limpeza profunda e voltar a colocar
as teclas mas eu deixo isso para outro
dia olha bom produto 10 10 este 10 10
também acho que sim voz misteriosa manda
para aqui para a mesa isso vamos embora
com força é que vai tatuagens este
produto é polémico porque eu não sei se
isto é muito confiável não é mas claro
se vem da te ou claro que é para confiar
mano nós temos aqui pois às vezes aqui
temos tatuagem para o braço grande tatu
mesmo com uma caveira mesmo tribal é
para isto mesmo da moda né olha aí
tatuagem mesmo da moda tem aqui várias
para os dedos tem uma chave tem ali umas
estrelas esta parece bacana esta vem
aqui mesmo ó
assim toma hoje vamos ser os mazes da
rua hoje vão todos olhar para mim com
aquela cara de respeito só porque ten
esta tatu não faz sentido hã até parece
que sei o que estou a fazer e agora pões
uma toalha molhada com pressão durante
alguns segundos eia vem já colou Olha já
não há nada a fazer e acho que já ficou
ih Até ficou a parte de cima não
acredito oh não eu devia ter recortado
esta parte Oh não olha mas entrou rápido
Oh
não olha ol Olha é qualquer
coisa isto não interessa ainda vou tempo
ainda vou tempo Ah olha para isto
funciona eu não sei se dá para ter esta
tatu por muito tempo né mas pelo menos
entrou agora a da mão acho que já entrou
[Música]
Ok falhou aqui um pouquinho olha mas
entrou nos pelos entrou nos pelos a aí
para arrancar
isto isto vai dar tão errado P malon Dao
p malon
da ai tá a puxar o pelo aqui tá
elá
olha olha
três Olha este entrou
bem aê estamos contat tu ou não estamos
curti curti o que é que nós temos aqui
Este é para zuki não é Ah é assim com
força assim com força faz lá faz lá faz
lá com força isso mulher com força isso
até matar a
barata isto é uma mantinha a ele vai
adorar ele vai adorar calma Já vais
tocar Calma calma ainda não ainda nãoa
Malta isto é uma mantinha para os
cachorros especialmente para a raça do
meu cão que é samoiedo mas dá para asis
dá para todo o animal que sofre no verão
Com altas temperaturas Mas ela é fresca
e ela passa um geladinho bom Como que lá
mão ele vai adorar isto o ideal é vocês
terem uma cama para o vosso cachorro e
colocarem isto por cima assim ele fica
com aquele toque mais fresco passa
melhor a noite descansa muito melhor e
para quem tem um animal muito peludo com
muito pelo Isto é perfeito que é isto
aqui que é isto vamos colocar aqui no
chão a ver se ele gosta deita deita
oh ele gostou
gostas gostas oh Malta acho que ele
adorou o sorriso diz tudo deita
deita Ok iso é um
obrigado
I agora não sei se ele gostou ou não ui
ui ui revoltou-se estou arrependido
estou arrependido Malta não
ISO Isto é suposto ser uma
cama que isso não é um brinquedo é uma
ai ai ai ai pronto desculpa
lá á is não eu quer is volta rif rif
está a passar aqui oh não oh
não calma zuk zuk isso é a tua cama nova
zuk meu amor isto é uma amig não é
suposto não é estes foram os produtos da
Timo já sabem Malta aí embaixo vocês têm
o link para baixarem a aplicação Se
quiserem podem usar também o meu código
promocional vocês vão ter descontos e e
muitos descontos e mais descontos
portanto se quiserem ver mais deixem o
vosso like comentem e até a próxima